The most dangerous sign of a copper
deficiency is not gray hair. It's not
cold hands or cold feet. It's not even
the loss of collagen which can give you
stretch marks. Copper protects us
against too much iron and helps us store
iron effectively. Copper also helps us
transport iron through the body safely.
The most dangerous problem with a copper
deficiency has to do with what it does
to iron. Here's why. Without enough
copper, you get the side effects of
iron, which are cerosis of the liver,
increased risk of developing pathogens,
the rusting out of the organs, the
damaging of your heart, all on top of
not being able to use iron in your
blood. So you're actually anemic.